hi I'm Eric Vox and there's a new
trailer for a game of Thrones Season 7
which is crazy because I feel like I'm
still recovering from the first trailer
a few weeks ago alright give me some air
HBO I'm just kidding smother me
HBO's monomania with Game of Thrones
footage this second trailer has even
more interesting shots and details that
you might miss little clues that could
predict what's going down in season 7 so
spoiler warning if you don't want to get
into any of that stuff seriously some of
our predictions have been weirdly right
in the past and if we are some of these
could end up being pretty huge spoilers
so you've been more anyway let's get
started don't frighten and loss on the
south side every battle everywhere
always and your mind
so this trailer opens with the amazing
music called light of the 7 which is the
same music that we heard open the season
6 finale winds of winter now this music
was composed by Ramin Djawadi but the
director that episode Miguel sapotes NIC
actually consulted on the dramatic
shifts of this music so the music alone
tells a story carefully leading each
character closer and closer to their
death and just like it did in that
episode this music says the same thing
in this trailer with Sansa now filling
in for Cersei as the badass queen
turning back towards the camera as every
other character confronts death and if
you're interested in the stuff the
lighted seven has even more secret
narrative elements that we broke down in
our season finale video last summer also
joining music is just always super
layered and interesting from a narrative
standpoint and use a lot of these
similar techniques in the last trailer
and you should definitely check out our
breakdown for that too now what is Santa
doing here it looks like she's in the
godswood in Winterfell walking away from
the heart tree and if you look closely
there's a figure standing behind her
actually this could be a reverse shot of
the scene that we saw in the winds of
winter when she walked away from
Littlefinger and that might be why we
hear Baelish his voice here giving Sansa
advice he's saying not to focus on one
geographic region of the war but to look
at the big picture like a chessboard
thinking cold moves ahead in fact this
game board motif which various compass
directions is another parallel to how
the first trailer began enemies to be
used to delish enemies to the south I'm
used to the moon now this trailer adds
an entire piece opens and closes with
Sansa who we don't really see anywhere
else in the trailer and I think there's
a really important reason for that but
I'll save it for the end of the video in
the meantime there's just so much more
to talk about so let's move on
[Music]
okay so in this section we see the
northern gate of Castle black open which
is from the last trailer but now we see
who its opening for looking at this
closely that's Mira dragging in bran on
the sledge so this is confirmation that
bran will finally return south of the
wall probably the Winterfell - as we see
later in this trailer but remember the
mark that the night king left on brands
armed allowed the White Walkers to break
through the protective magical barrier
around the great weirwood tree way up
north and that might also apply to the
magical barrier that's supposed to be in
the wall to keep White Walkers out so do
you think bran crossing under the wall
is something that could doom the wall
let me know in the comments but then
moving on we see John and wildling furs
somewhere north of the wall probably and
then we get ditched shot in King's
Landing notice the castle towers in the
background as crimson Lannister banners
hang down
so clearly Cersei has redecorated the
city from Baratheon insignia to
Lannister lion like she did in the
throne room in the last trailer
replacing the seven pointed star with a
lion but notice here how the citizens of
King's Landing are clapping and take a
look at these soldiers so who are these
guys they aren't wearing white
Kingsguard capes or red Lannister armor
so it's hard to tell but I think these
guys might be you're on Greyjoy soldiers
they don't look exactly like they did at
the Kingsmoot last season but their
armor and helmets are similar colors to
the sails on the Greyjoy boat so why
would your own men be celebrated in
King's Landing
well in my last trailer breakdown I look
closely at that shot in the throne room
with Cersei talking to someone who kind
of grossed her out and I suggested that
that could be your own Greyjoy offering
to use the fleet to protect King's
Landing probably an exchange or
something that Cersei wouldn't want to
give but my theory is that because
Cersei is out of allies who would be
forced to make this kind of alliance now
we get further confirmation of that
prediction later in the trailer but here
I think this is Gironde men returning to
King's Landing with the people the city
thanking them for protecting it from sea
but let me know in the comments who you
think these soldiers are and if you
think there's anything to this theory of
an alliance between Euron and Cersei and
before I move on there is this shot of
Daenerys at Dragonstone running her hand
along the Westeros map table created by
her ancestor Aegon the conquerer so as I
pointed out in the last trailer
breakdown this could be Daenerys showing
that she's boy
to repeat that conquest and notice how
most of the pieces already knocked over
except this one which looks like it
could be the same Lannister lion piece
that we saw get knocked over in the last
trailer and I think Daenerys pausing
here is her reaching out to do that
maybe to signal her desire to take
Cersei off the Iron Throne
or her desire to attack the Lannisters
home at Casterly Rock and Lance port
more on that later but let's move on
[Music]
centuries our families fought together
against their common enemy despite their
differences together okay starting off
this section there's this shot of the
beaches of Dragonstone and it's hard to
tell but the tiny figures arriving by
boat look like they could be John and
sir Davos and their crew and look even
further behind them you can barely make
out a 3-person greeting party which
could be Tyrion Varys may be grey worm
may be Daenerys herself and so this
could be part of John and sir Davos is
diplomatic mission to Dragonstone to try
to get Daenerys to join them in their
fight against the White Walkers next
this shot of arya on horseback and based
on her facial expression here it looks
like she could be coming up the hill to
see her home of Winterfell like the
camera is gonna pan around to show the
Winterfell towers that she finally makes
its dramatic homecoming then after this
shot of Jamie and King's Landing and a
shot of Littlefinger and a blade
sharpening for the last trailers there's
this interesting image of Daenerys
walking along the Dragonstone beach now
this could be Daenerys walking out to
greet John or certainly after she
arrives home but check out the shape in
the red colored rock formation behind
her it kind of looks like the head of
drogon and it would be super awesome if
this shot it's Daenerys meeting John and
then the camera pans over and we see
John is standing in front of a rock
formation that's in the shape of a
wolf's head or hell maybe in the shape
of another dragon now that we know that
John is half Targaryen now there are
actually a lot of interesting
consequences of John Targaryen bloodline
that the show might explore and I go
into all of them including his claims
the Iron Throne and what his real name
is in another video I made about the
unresolved mysteries left to do on Game
of Thrones so go check that out now over
this notice the speech that John Gibbs
and centuries of families fought
together
against a common enemy now the editing
makes it seem like he's talking to
Daenerys here like this is part of its
pitch to join his mission but when he
stopped to think about it the last fight
that John is talking about is the war
that the northern families joined forces
together again Daenerys is Targaryen
family so this audio is probably John
talking to the other northern Lords it's
just ironic that we see one of the
losers of that war Daenerys as John is
alluding to it now this banner that
Daenerys pairs down it's a stag
emblazoned with a flaming heart remember
that's the sigil of Stannis Baratheon
who took Dragonstone from the Targaryen
and then later abandoned it when he
sailed north to join Jonathan Whalley
I think this shot with the banner is
meant to parallel John's homecoming in
Winterfell after the Battle of the
bastard when they finally tore down the
banners of the strangers who took over
their ancestral home and replaced them
with the natural stark banners so I
think Daenerys is doing the same here
for claiming her ancestral home from the
people who took it from her and before I
move on we see this amazing wide shot of
Daenerys three dragons flying toward
Dragonstone while Tyrion stands on the
cliff
looking a little nervous actually have a
prediction about what's going on here
but I'll get to it later for now let's
move on we need to do the same if we can
supply
the enemy is real
okay after this quick shot of Seon as
the stance on what looks like a ship on
fire more on that in a second we get
this interesting shot of grey worm on a
different boat headed into this cave now
I think this cave could be a secret back
entrance to Casterly Rock and here's why
I think that tyrion told beerus that his
father Tywin put him in charge of the
sewer system of Casterly Rock
I probably put me in charge of all the
drains and systems in Casterly Rock was
another flowed better and all the [ __ ]
found its way to the sea now that means
that Tyrion probably knows all the
drainage routes underneath the city and
I think that he's going to share this
knowledge with great worm in the
unsullied so that they can sneak a small
task force into the city in Sackett from
the inside out actually remember grey
worm took down the city of young Kai in
a similar mission in season 3 next
there's a shot at Brienne and Podrick
returning to Winterfell and a very quick
shot of the Hound Sandor Clegane
somewhere probably way up north I
remember he joined up with the
Brotherhood last season so it's looking
like he in the Brotherhood will be the
ones joining John in this mission north
of the wall that we've seen clips of in
these trailers we also see more shots of
this big battle which I'm assuming is
all from the same Battle of Daenerys
forces against the Lannisters first
there's this shot of an unsullied
soldier going down in a barrage of
arrows fired by these Lannister archers
and notice how Jaime and Bronn are the
ones commanding them so that means Jaime
will be part of this battle these same
battle remember that will feature a
massive dragon and I just can't wait to
see the look on Jamie's face and that
sting shows up there's also a quick shot
of the moment that feeds off rocky
Calvary collides with the Lannister
shield and yeah I assume some CGI went
into this shot because they're not going
to like RAM real horses into real people
and shields so when you think about that
I love the detail of the Splinter is
exploding there's also a quick angle of
this ship on fire with someone jumping
onto the deck and yeah again I think
this is part of that naval battle
between Yara and Theon forces and you're
on fleet next there's this shot of a
flock of crows flying over what looks
like a massive army of whites and white
walkers and check out this crows eye
he's clearly being worked into by bran
here so maybe this is the three-eyed
Ravens promise coming true and bran is
finally flying here
you'll never walk again but you will fly
now it's interesting that the night king
seems to look up at brand here like it's
able to see through the worg and spot
brand and of course that's what scares
brand out of the vision now this could
be the market at the night King less on
brand making him visible to the night
clean again and before I move on brand
wakes up sitting in this wheelchair
which looks very similar to one that
prints Doran Martell had actually kind
of feels like bran is Professor X coming
out of cerebro but in this case the
regrow is the heart tree of the
Winterfell godswood that's right bran is
finally home and who is he talking to
here now first I thought this was Sir
Davos who's maybe like acting brand for
information on how far south the White
Walkers are and by the way there's
actually a super interesting theory
about where the White Walkers are headed
and what they want and I go into all
those details and our other Game of
Thrones unresolved mysteries video so
definitely check that out what I'm
wondering if this guy isn't sir Davos
but it's another character now currently
on the show bran is the only character
who definitely knows that John true
parents are Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen except one other person
Howland Reed
now Helen Reed is Mira's father and he
was there with Ned Stark at the Tower of
joy so maybe when brand returns to
Winterfell with Meera Howland will
arrive and confirm the brand what
exactly it was that he saw so do you
think Helen Reed will appear on Game of
Thrones
let me know what you think in the
comments but let's move on so always
been
[Music]
okay this next section starts with the
craziest shot in this trailer
lightning Lord of the Brotherhood
without banners holding a flaming sword
now we've seen him with a sword on fire
before remember back in season 3 when he
dueled with the Hound but this one looks
like it lights up on its own now this is
huge
obviously a connect Barrack to the
prophecy of azor Ahai reborn now
remember that figure is supposed to
carry a flaming sword and engquist the
others or the White Walkers now I'm not
a hundred percent that this shot is
confirmation that barrack is or high but
we do know that he is a champion of the
Lord of Light remember Thoris of mere
did resurrect him from the dead the same
way that Melisandre did for Jon Snow so
I do predict that barrack thinks pieces
or high reborn and that that will be the
purpose of this small mission with Jon
and hormones in the Brotherhood north of
the wall I think they're on their way to
the White Walkers because they hope that
Barret will defeat them as missoura high
is prophesied to but because this is a
world created by george RR martin and
i'm think he really cares about
prophecies that much I really don't
think things will go down this neatly
but what do you think about this do you
think this flaming sword makes beric
Dondarrion the top candidate to be as or
high reborn and the prince that was
promised let me know in the comments up
next we see these shots of your on
Greyjoy fleet making its way to King's
Landing the sails have the Greyjoy
Kraken sigil and the side sails are the
same design that your own ship have in
the book now I think this is either part
of your ons initial peaceful arrival to
King's Landing to form his alliance with
Cersei or his post victory homecoming
but more on that later
we also see more shots of the unsullied
as they sacked the city and we see one
group of them opening the doors from the
inside allowing more of them to pour in
from the outside so here's what I think
is going down here I think this will be
a part of a two-pronged attack a smaller
task force making into Casterly Rock
from the drains under the city while
more are invading from the outside
actually I think that since we saw that
one unsullied soldier earlier on getting
hit by arrows fired from Lannister
arrows for behind their front lines I
think it's possible that this whole
battle could be taking place outside the
city of Casterly Rock with Jaime and
Bronn and the Lannisters defending their
home city now I could be wrong about the
like this battle could just be taking
place somewhere else or in a totally
different part of the season but the
section does show us more parts of this
battlefield wherever it is Jamie
emotionally charging on horseback
through the flame and another angle of
the clothing shot from the last trailer
with the dragon flying overhead - just
Rocky blood riders and from this angle
you could make out that someone is
riding on the back of that dragon now my
first guess is obviously generic but
it's kind of hard to tell which dragon
this is now initially assumed it was
drogue on the largest with black and red
scales but it also kind of looks like
ragel that Dragon has greenish and red
scales in which case maybe this isn't
Daenerys on the back of this dragon
maybe it's someone else for example
Tyrion in fact that could be what's
going on in that earlier shot with
Tyrion looking uncomfortable at
Dragonstone like perhaps Daenerys is
ordering him to ride the dragon into
battle because remember Tyrion was able
to get along pretty well with reg all
back in Mereen when he Unchained them
and I know it seems like I'm kind of
grasping here but if this is all true
this would be a super emotional battle
for Tyrion leading a deadly charge on
his home city feeling like a traitor to
his Lannister men specifically his
brother Jaime the only Lannister he
still probably loved this would be an
epic battle of brother against brother
and if this is Tyrion riding ragel that
could just mean Daenerys divided her
forces and that's actually a tactic used
by her ancestor Aegon the conquerer very
rarely to use all three dragons in one
battle like usually he would send its
sisters on the other dragons to other
places because you really don't need
more than one dragon in a battle so
maybe Daenerys has taken her other two
dragons somewhere else now of course
there's also the lingering mystery over
Tyrion possible connection with the
dragons and the Targaryen and I
discussed that in our other Game of
Thrones unresolved mystery video so go
check it out but for this video let me
know in the comments do you think that
we'll see Tyrion ever ride a dragon and
do you want Tyrion to have to face his
brother Jaime in battle let me know
let's move on
okay this section opens with Jarrah and
Theon nervously looking up at an
explosion on their ship so yeah things
are looking pretty bad for them in this
naval battle with their uncle you're on
and I have a feeling that's a way this
will go down is that maybe yarn beyond
won't die here but these trailers have
been showing us a lot of yarn Theon in
this very dismal situation
so honestly I'd be a little surprised if
this is actually the place they're going
to die rather I think this could go one
of two other ways like maybe they
managed to escape like they might be the
two figures that would sell plunging the
water last trailer or they could be
taken as hostages by Iran back to King's
Landing I actually think that part of
the reason all those people in King's
Landing were clapping is that the
Greyjoy's brought some hostages back
with him but if it's not beyond in Yara
it could be someone else who's with them
in their fleet and since we know that
there were a lot of people who were
teaming up and American fleet including
the Tyrells in the Martel I think it's
more likely that those hostages will be
ilaria sand and/or the sand snakes
remember they were the ones who killed
Cersei and daughter Marcella so maybe
that's part of the alliance that Cersei
makes with Euron like she wants him to
bring her back the women who killed her
daughter and maybe she wants to let the
mountain do a repeat of what ilaria saw
him do to her boyfriend Oberyn now these
next shots show the Lannister troops
getting into formation and they're using
the same Spears or the shield tactics
that we saw the Bolton's views and last
season's battle the bastards actually in
our breakdown of the episode we explore
how that battle formation was inspired
by battles in real Roman history so
definitely watch that video to see how
Game of Thrones uses these interesting
real-world battle history tactics to
inspire their battle scenes but next is
this interesting shot of Jon Snow and
his men stranded on this rock surrounded
by white it's going to look like another
nightmare hardhome situation and this
location looks a lot like the fifth of
the first men that we've seen earlier in
the series real closely the background
these whites are covering the mountain
sides like ants also if you look closely
over on the right I think we can make
out the night king sitting on this horse
flanked by a few other white walkers who
are watching all this go down now
fighting alongside John is Barrack with
its flaming sword some people are saying
that looks more like the Hound but
notice how this guy is wearing the same
high collar and fur
that beric were in that earlier shot I
also assume that tormund and the hound
will also appear in the saddle now a big
question here how are John and his guys
supposed to get out of this impossible
situation
now unless we're seeing John death here
to me the only way to get out of this is
some air support from above specifically
maybe Daenerys dinner dragon or maybe
one of the Dragons without Danny like
Vaziri on the cream and gold colored one
who I don't think we've seen a lone
anywhere I'm predicting that they might
swoop in and torch some of these whites
to remember fire is the only thing that
can kill them or maybe carry John to
safety like those great Eagles in the
Lord of the Rings and there's a quick
shot of Masson day and grey worm and
then this interesting shot of someone
who looks like the Hound but mostly at
the shot he's not wearing any pants but
it's really short short and this
location looks sunnier and warmer I
don't think the Hound is in any location
like that so this could be another one
of brand visions in the past perhaps
showing the day that Sanders face was
cruelly burned next is a shot of John
and Davos at Dragonstone that rock wall
behind them is the same one from the
beach before this could be their
reaction shot as Daenerys is coming up
to greet them now there's a quick shot
of John swing his Valyrian steel sword
Longclaw at a white walker Dothraki
riders galloping through flames and then
this interesting shot of a beach now who
is this character collapsing weakly into
the water now it's kind of hard to tell
but to me this guy kind of looks like
Gendry yeah I know it's great injury is
rumoured to come back this season and
maybe he's just exhausted from rowing a
boat for three seasons I don't know let
me know who you think this is in the
comments then after a shot of Euron
swinging at someone in this naval battle
there's this freaky shot of drogon and a
close-up of his feet and I'm pretty sure
that's Daenerys writing on his back and
that's dragons throne in the background
so this could be the point of view of
Tyrion and this is the moment that if my
theory is right he and Daenerys split up
on the backs of different dragons okay
let's move on to this final section I
miss Mary's fool and the white wings
blow the lone wolf dies
the Quebec flood okay so this final
section is super mysterious first we see
this overhead shot that was on the last
trailer now I pointed out then that this
character is carrying a warhammer which
remember was the weapon of choice of
Robert Baratheon and that could mean
that this character is Robert's son who
is an armory expert Gendry and this
might be proof that he'll join up with
the Brotherhood in this mission with
John and torment we also see a shot of a
lone rider who looks like he's wounded
now this could be John escaping from
this battle with the white walkers but
then most interestingly there's this
shot of John from behind as he faces off
with the whites
now those lanes of the background are
interesting I would say they're from
barracks sword but everything is so
freakin cold up in this location I don't
know if this sword could have caused
explains to get that high so yeah I'm
thinking that this is dragon fire from a
dragon that maybe picked them up and
saved them and that dragon fire could be
why the whites are hanging back here but
let's talk about the stances interesting
voice over here the language dies but
the best what a lot of you were asking
about this line about the lone wolf in
the pack and it's actually a direct
quote from her father Ned Stark who said
the same line to Arya in the first book
a game of Thrones this was when he was
trying to get her to stop fighting with
her sister Sansa basically trying to get
her to learn that Starks need to stick
together for when the darkness comes and
this quote is something that comes back
to Arya throughout the books actually
she remembers it when she thinks bran
and Rickon died when she's at Harrenhal
and she remembers it at the beginning of
the book for believing now that Ned had
it's backwards
and that her pack of Starks had all died
off leaving her as the surviving lone
wolf now when Sansa says this line we
don't see where she is or who she's
talking to so maybe this blind that she
tells Arya when they reunite to call
back the time when they saw each other
when they were girls with this stupid
animosity and now they both grown older
and matured and they understand how much
they need each other right at the same
time notice dances dark tone as she says
these words snows fool and the white
wings blood
now the last time we heard Santa talk
like this it was last season at the end
of the Battle of the bastards when she
sent him to Ramsay Bolton to die so if
this is a similar kind of threat who is
the lone wolf that Sansa is referring to
now I think this connects back to the
opening of this trailers when
Littlefinger gave stance to that advice
my dad's a bottle everywhere always in
your mind and looking back those words
now kind of sound like final words
before someone died so yeah I think
Sansa could be talking a little finger
here in a lot of ways he's a lone wolf
he's a solo operator he doesn't really
rely on family or companions to get
stuff done also he's been trying to get
Sansa to turn against Jon against her
own blood to divide up the stark pact
and now it looks like the surviving
stark kids are all reunited in
Winterfell and the pact has survived so
I predict that Sansa is doing like a Sam
Jackson Bible verse and pulp fiction
coldly invoking her father to avenge the
man who betrayed him who is now trying
to turn his children against each other
finally putting him into that game but
who do you think Sansa is talking to
here who do you think is the lone wolf
that will die let me know your thoughts
on this question and all the other
questions that I brought up throughout
this video comment down below and share
this video to keep the discussion going
on Twitter you can tweet directly at me
at EI vos or new rock stars at new
rockstars and subscribe to this channel
to keep up with all the Game of Thrones
videos that we're going to be putting
out you heard me
we're putting out here at new rock stars
you can also buy our love and really
just be a more active part of this
channel by contributing to new rock
stars on patreon big thanks to all of
our current patrons especially Kenny
Smith alright thanks for watching bye
you